I'm talking to you today about
webassembly and asking the question is
this going to be the death of JavaScript
and yeah might not be the best meetup to
ask a question like that if you feel
like throwing something at me that's
fine just wait till the end that's all
cool so I'm going to start off in
typical fashion with a brief history of
the web and I'm I know the web is a
complex complex set of technologies I'm
mostly going to be looking at JavaScript
and as I think most people have worked
with JavaScript for a while know the
language itself was invented in a very
short space of time by a chap called
Brendan Eich he invented it in just 10
days and back in 1995 the web was a very
very different place it wasn't the kind
of dynamic single page app react type
environment that we know right now it
was mostly static pages the occasional
form and JavaScript was there to just
add a little bit of interactivity on top
of an otherwise pretty static web since
then other languages have come along and
Java applets ActiveX flash you might
have used some of these Silverlight my
apologies if you've used that dart and
so on and that's it that's the history
of the web done because 2018 it's still
JavaScript it's still only JavaScript
JavaScript is the only language which is
officially supported by the web but the
interesting thing is the way that we're
using JavaScript has changed a lot in
the 20 odd years since it was originally
invented I guess without going into too
much detail one of the things that's
that that I've observed is that we
collectively we write a lot of
JavaScript and when I say a lot I mean a
lot of JavaScript and just the other day
I started up a new react app so I used
the create react app package so this is
me creating a new application and then
finding all the the JavaScript files
within the projects and doing a line
count 79 thousand lines of JavaScript
that's a lot of JavaScript and the thing
is weird we're using JavaScript for far
more than just adding interactivity on
webpages which is the world that Brendan
Eich was was creating JavaScript for
we're using it as build tools we're
using it on the server we're using our
mobile devices we're using it all
over the place but the weird thing is
the way that we're using the language
itself has changed quite a bit
many years ago I guess when I first
dodged using JavaScript it was quite
simple you'd open up a text editor you'd
write some JavaScript it would be served
over HTTP and exactly the code that you
had written would be executed within the
browser that doesn't happen very often
these days
typically the code that you rights will
be transpiled it will be minified it
will be bundled it'll go through all
kinds of really quite advanced
transformations and by the time it lands
in your browser it will look a bit like
a garbled mess and that's led a few
people to consider javascript to be the
assembly language of the web it's it's a
compilation target as well as the
language we use to write our
applications but this is where I am
moving my cursor this is where the
problems start to surface because
JavaScript actually isn't a very good
assembly language and it's no surprise
again reflecting on the context within
which it was invented in the first place
it was never designed to be an assembly
language it was never designed to be a
compilation target and to understand why
it's a bad compilation target why it's
not a good assembly language you have to
understand a little bit more about how
javascript is executed within the
browser so this is a diagram that I took
from a a Mozilla blog post where they
were giving a rough overview of how
JavaScript is executed in the browser so
the first bits on the left hand side is
a bunch of characters come along over
HTTP and they're passed into a thing
called an abstract syntax tree it's a
it's a tree like representation of your
code after that it generates some PI
byte code which is then run within an
interpreter and then this is where the
really clever stuff starts happening
that many years ago that was it that was
the way that JavaScript was executed
these days a lot of work has gone into
optimizing JavaScript so what will
happen is the runtime will start to look
at your code look at the execution to
make certain assumptions if you've got a
function that is always called with a
pair of integers for example it will
generate an optimized version of that
and the execution of that function will
become faster and I think it was the
Safari browser has something like
or different tiers of optimization and
the your code sort of moves up and down
these tiers so as it can spot
optimizations it moves up a tier but if
the assumptions it makes about your code
is false it has to push it back down
again it's really really complicated and
as you can imagine this isn't an
efficient compilation target and how
does this actually manifest itself one
of the things that as a JavaScript
developer most of us or pretty much all
of us are concerned about is the
execution speed of our code within the
browser and there's the one of the most
important things that what's something
that people have been focusing on a lot
recently is is the time to interactive
the time it takes to load all your code
and actually start doing something and
this is a timeline that I shamelessly
borrowed from this fantastic blog post
by Lynne Clark it's it's well worth the
read she does an excellent job of
describing why web assembly is needed
I'm just grabbing this diagram here this
is a timeline that approximates the
execution of JavaScript within your
browser so the first thing it does is it
has to pass your pass your old
JavaScript the next is it has to compile
and optimize it and then potentially it
will have to re optimize it and then
afterwards you've got a certain amount
of execution and garbage collection the
timeline you see here the past time the
compile time the optimized time has a
significant impact on how long it takes
for your application to actually execute
and be interactive so this is again why
I'm saying that JavaScript isn't a good
an assembly language this isn't your
designing it from scratch you wouldn't
design it like this and I guess this
this little quote here I think
summarizes it quite nicely this is a
quote from the team that created web
assembly and they mentioned that the web
has become the most ubiquitous
application platform ever and yet by
historical accidents the only natively
supported programming language for that
platform is JavaScript and this is
coming from a bunch of guys who are web
developers and they love javascript so
it's not they're not against the
JavaScript languages itself but the the
situation we find ourselves is is a
weird quirk of history so that brings me
on to webassembly if you look at the web
assembly specification the web assembly
websites they describe it as a new
portable size and load time efficient
format suitable for compilation to the
web so it was designed specifically to
solve some of the problems I've been
talking about now hands up if you've
heard of ASM jeaious before okay that's
that's good so an interesting parts of
the history of web assembly is quite
tightly related to asm.js
don't worry if you've not heard of it
before it doesn't matter I'll give you a
quick illustration of what it is and
hopefully that will help you understand
some of the design goals of web assembly
so ASM Jas was a bit of an experiment it
was actually a bit of a wacky idea that
was created by Mozilla I think around
about five years ago and at that point
in time there were various other plugin
like technologies being considered in
that the standard plug-in model is you
take some other runtime and you kind of
bolt it onto the side of the browser
that's how that's how plugins works and
at that time there were other people
considering other plug-in style models
whereas the Mozilla team came up with
this slightly crazy idea of why don't we
create this sort of virtual runtime that
sits within the JavaScript virtual
machine so they said okay we need memory
so we'll just have an array that can be
our memory we need instructions so we'll
create effectively patterns within our
JavaScript that represent those
instructions so I'll quickly illustrate
what it is and then show you why that is
a great demonstration of a slightly
better way of doing things so here's a
here's a bit of code this is some asm.js
code don't but don't worry too much
about the detail pop this is a function
written in C that does your standard
Fibonacci calculation I'm compiling it
using a tool called M scripting into a
SMGs and that's what you see at the
bottom there so a s MJS is JavaScript
but it's a particularly peculiar looking
kind of JavaScript I'll highlight a few
things I won't go into all the details
but the first thing you'll see here is
the reassignment of the arguments to
this function so a equals plus a so
typically you'd use that to kind of
coerce something to be a number B equals
B or zero which means that it's exactly
the same as it was previously these are
type hints these are telling the runtime
that
one of these is a floats and one of them
is an integer you can see at the bottom
it's returning plus C again you can see
the pattern here that res in my C code
is a float you can see that we've got in
the JavaScript code a for loop and a s
MJS doesn't support for loops here
you've got a do while instead so that
all looks a bit crazy you might be
asking why on earth would you do that
getting back to the way that JavaScript
executes within the browser you can see
what they were trying to achieve with a
s MJS so what happens with within a
browser that understands it well firstly
if the browser doesn't understand is MJS
it doesn't matter it's just plain old
JavaScript and it executes says normal
however if the JavaScript recognizes a s
MJS and it does that by looking at this
use ASM literal string at the top what
it does is it starts doing the usual
thing it it parses it into an abstract
syntax tree but then immediately it
spots the patterns it effectively reads
the ASM J s assembly language and
immediately is able to push it right up
the write up to quite a highly optimized
version of the code skipping some of the
quite and time-consuming interpreter
steps and optimization steps so as you
can imagine this is quite a neat idea
but I think s MJ s was only ever put
together as a a technical proof of
concepts because one of the things they
could never get around is the very first
bit the bit at the beginning their
parsing the JavaScript language and as
you can see it's a s MJ s is itself
pretty verbose so as you can imagine
parsing it to the abstract syntax tree
has got quite a lot of overhead but a s
MJ s was a great proof of concept that
there might be a better way of doing
things and there early demos were really
quite impressive
the M scripting tool that they use also
had a logic in it to convert Open GL
codes into WebGL code and they were able
to take some game engines and do some
pretty impressive things so a s MJ s
pointed pointed people towards a a
different and interesting approach to
solving this problem which was quite
different than the standard sort of
plug-in model as a result the web
assembly working group was formed and it
was formed in 21
fifteen with with representation from
all the main browser vendors and a bunch
of others and quite impressively within
the space of two years they managed to
design their MVP scope for web assembly
and and get it released in the wild so
in November last year and it was turned
on in all browsers all major browsers
without the need for flags
so it's officially out there in the wild
it's also in node version 8 and Beyond
and just earlier this month w3c
published their first public draft as
well so they managed to get this done in
a very short space of time
and I think it was mostly because ASM
j/s effectively created a blueprint to
demonstrate some of the concepts here so
I've talked a lot about web assembly but
I haven't actually shown you any web
assemblies so I thought the best way to
do that was to actually and show some
code and talk around the code just so
you get a better idea of what it
actually looks like in in real life so
switching to code this is obviously
where all goes horribly wrong okay so
I'm going to start with a very very
simple example this is a function that
adds two numbers together and even
though this is visual vs code that's
actually C which is horrible and dirty
and makes me want to wash my hands but
there you go there's an ad function and
what happens is with my build my tool
chain I'm not going to go into too much
detail about that my tall chain is
compiling that into web assembly and
there are two distinct formats that you
can use to view your web assembly the
the obvious one is Oh tiny tiny is in
hex so the output of web assembly is a
binary format so again recalling how
javascript is is processed by your
browser it no longer has to parse the
characters into an abstract syntax tree
it's a compact binary format but the
more useful way of looking at it is the
actually they've changed the file
extension for this it's the white format
web assembly text format it's a shame
they didn't go for web assembly text
format WTF as an extension that would've
been awesome but anyway this is my C
code so I'm adding two two numbers
together and this is what it looks like
as web assembly
so a few little bits and pieces here
we've got the concept of memory so
memory within webassembly is very
similar to the memory concept they
invented with a s MJ s memory is a
contiguous array of bytes and that
memory is actually shared between the
webassembly runtime in the JavaScript
runtime so you can you can make writes
to the web assembly memory from your
JavaScript code it defines functions
it's got a whole load of instructions
there are about 60 yards instructions
and it works as a stack machine if
you've done anything if you've done any
programming with some kind of assembly
language of some sort the full
instruction set will look quite familiar
to you web assembly can also export and
import functions so you can export to a
JavaScript function from your web
assembly module so you can export a web
assembly function from your module and
invoke it from JavaScript and vice versa
you can import a JavaScript module so
that it can be executed by your
JavaScript so that's that's my web
assembly and we've got the binary format
and I'll show you how it's actually
loaded instantiated instantiated and
executed now because I can't be bothered
by with creating an HTML page to house
this I'm just doing it within node but
it's pretty similar within the browser
so we're we're loading the web assembly
binary format and we're constructing a
module from it and then from the module
we're creating an instance from the
instance we can invoke the exported
functions so here if I execute ad it
tells me that to add 3 equals 5 so here
I've gone from JavaScript X it's
executed and web assembly function
within the web assembly virtual machine
and return the result that's all pretty
straightforward I'll show you now some
of the areas where it gets a little bit
tricky and now I feel like I'm showing
you a bit of a tip of the iceberg in
that it's not a simple case of just
writing a whole load of code and web
assembly creating an API layer and
invoking it from JavaScript at the
moment is relatively challenging to do
that one of the reasons for doing that
is that web assembly has a very small
number of built-in types only has four
types and they're all numeric so it's
got two floating point and two integer
types what that means is if you want to
do something with
something a little bit more advanced
like strings it gets quite complicated
so my next little demo is just something
which returns a simple string from my
web assembly function and renders it
from JavaScript so I'll just and put
back there okay so this is my C code so
what I've done is I've created a a hello
Azzam string which is reference as a
character pointer and I've got a
function which is get message ref so
what that's doing is is returning the
reference to the message if we look at
the compiled output it's a little bit
more complicated this time we've got
these things called data sections within
our web assembly module and these are
basically ways of instantiating your web
assembly module memory to a known state
and here you can see it's actually
writing hello wasm it's writing
something else which i think is the
offset to actually I'm not sure I'll
have to check that it's writing
something else and here is how it's
actually executed within JavaScript and
here you can see that simply by changing
it from an example based on integer
types to strings
things get a little bit more complicated
so we've seen this bit of code before
this loads my our web assembly binary
and instantiate some odd module but now
to return the string the the get message
ref function isn't returning a string
it's returning an integer which is an
index to the location of that string
within linear memory so I'm having to
get hold of a reference to my linear
memory create a crater buffer and
iterate over that buffer populating it
with going byte by byte across my linear
memory reading the data route and if I
execute it it does indeed say hello
Azzam and that's by all means not an
exhaustive is the exhaustive
demonstration of web assembly but
hopefully it gives you a bit of a feel
for how ever how you use a web assembly
module for win from within JavaScript
and some of the current limitations that
there are so a little bit more in the
web assembly architecture so web
assembly itself is a stack machine as I
mentioned it has four built-in types 67
instructions importantly it's designed
to support streaming compilation so
there are some features that are
specific to web assembly
which reflect the context its used
within for the vast majority of use
cases your code is being streamed over
HTTP so it makes sense that webassembly
can be compiled in in a streaming
fashion and what that means is your your
your browser is able to chop up the web
assembly module and compile it in
parallel on multiple threads so again
it's been designed to be very very fast
it also has some very simple validation
rules JavaScript and any other web-based
language has a lot of validation rules
that ensure security web assembly is
just the same but again they've been
designed in such a way that they can be
processed and in serial is it streamed
in and as I mentioned before it exports
imports functions and has a concept of
shared linear memory with JavaScript now
one of the first questions that people
ask when they look at web assembly is oh
great this is going to be SuperDuper
performance it's gonna be really really
fast and I must admit I've read a lot of
blog posts which makes some quite quite
impressive and to be honest quite
incorrect claims about the performance
of web assembly I've seen blog posts
claiming that it's a hundred times
faster than JavaScript unfortunately
most of those blog posts suffer from the
classic problem of doing micro
benchmarking and either bench
benchmarking the wrong thing as well so
what I did was created a slightly more
representative test case I created a a
Mandelbrot and rendered that using C
JavaScript and a bunch of different
mechanisms for for generating web
assembly modules and I thought I
compared the performance of them and as
you can see the black line here is the
native performance so that's my C code
compiled directly on my Mac and executed
natively and the interesting observation
immediately is wow javascript is really
really fast
it's only about 20% slower rendering a
Mandelbrot and that's because of the
many many years that's gone into
compiler optimization for JavaScript
disappointingly when I ran it within web
assembly it was actually a little bit
slower and using wisdom assembly scripts
and a few other different approaches I
eventually through a number of
optimizations managed to make it just a
little bit faster than JavaScript so I
must admit I was a little bit
disappointed by that
I've had a look at other benchmarks and
other results and most importantly the
the paper that was published by the web
assembly team the accepted sort of
general feeling is that web assembly
should be around about 20 to 30 percent
faster at runtime execution than
JavaScript but because javascript is is
really quite fast there are there isn't
that much of a performance gain to be
made where they expect webassembly to
beat javascript significantly is the
past time and the initial compilation
time so the time to interactive with web
assembly should theoretically be a lot
less than with javascript so in the
future one of the things i mentioned was
that web assembly was developed over a
really quite short space of time and
partly that was because they had a SMGs
as a kind of reference implementation
another reason is the current web
assembly release is very much an MVP
they were quite aggressive about
ensuring that they had a very small set
of features so that they could release
quickly and the idea is that they're
going to be releasing new features over
the over the coming years so some of the
things that it doesn't have at the
moment is a garbage collector and I'll
explain why that's a bit bit of a pain
later on in the future it will also have
threading support a thing called host
bindings which is a way as I showed you
the interface between JavaScript and web
assembly is a little complicated at the
moment and if you want to start doing
Dom manipulation from web assembly
that's hard with host bindings in the
future that will become a lot easier so
one of the final things I want to look
at is webassembly language support and
what some people are actually doing with
the language so I showed you a little
bit of writing a bit of C code as a way
to show you what web assembly actually
looks like the text formats and so on
but most people aren't going to write
web assembly in its its machine code
well in its binary format or in the text
format most people are going to want to
use a language maybe C maybe not rust go
people are going to be using other
languages and increasing web assembly as
a compilation target so I'm going to
quickly look at the different languages
and their current level of support so
the first one is C or C++
and this is the the very first language
that gains webassembly support and again
that's due to its heritage from ASM Jas
there's a tool called M scriptum that
you can use to compile C to web assembly
an M script and does a lot more than
just a straightforward compilation it
has as I've mentioned it's got the Open
GL to WebGL bindings and it's got a
whole load of other things that make it
quite easy to take an existing C
codebase and compile it to web assembly
and put all the glue that's required
around it to actually make it work and
as I mentioned it was originally used to
create the ASM GS concept some of the
practical things I've seen people do
with it there's a there's a company that
have a thing called PS PDF kit and it's
basically a PDF renderer and just last
year they started exploring the use of
web assembly so they've got a C++ code
base and they explored the use of web
assembly as a way of using exactly the
same code base to do PDF rendering on
the web and they they found it quite a
good experience they managed to create
something which I think they're going to
actually ship as a as a product and with
very good performance this one's a fun
one JSC so the JavaScript core which is
the JavaScript machine that runs within
within WebKit is itself written in C++
now using M scripting you can compile
C++ to web assembly so what that means
is you can take javascriptcore
compile it to web assembly and then run
it on top of your JavaScript virtual
machine so what this is is the the
Safari JavaScript virtual machine
compiled to web assembly running on
Chrome which is great it's exactly what
you need finally one thing you'll
probably notice here is at the moment a
lot of people are essentially
experimenting with this technology there
are you won't find a huge number of
really practical use cases yet I think
that's still to come although where I
work at Scott logic we've done a bit of
work with a company called active
financial and they provide
they provide market data for people that
need high-frequency data so people that
are doing an algorithmic trading for
example and all of their distribution
logic all their serialization logic is
written in C and C++
and they've been getting a lot of
requests from from their their clients
who want to start using it
consuming this data from within
JavaScript either perhaps AWS and a
lambda function or perhaps within the
browser so we help them take their C++
code compile it to web assembly and use
exactly the same code to to to pass
their packets of data and deliver their
high-frequency data to the web so that's
something that we were able to achieve
with web assembly oh that should say she
C sharp that's a mistake
anyway so there's C C++ that's the story
and Java and c-sharp these ones are a
little bit more challenging because as
you I'm sure you're aware Java and
c-sharp and languages that both rely on
garbage collection whereas C C++ you
manually manage the lifecycle of your
objects and because web assembly doesn't
have garbage collection yet that means
it's a it's quite a problem it's quite a
challenge to take Java and c-sharp code
and compile it to web assembly there's
an experimental project called Blaser
and that's become an official I think
asp.net experiment and which uses mono
some of you may be aware of mono as a
way to run Java and c-sharp within web
assembly and what they're doing is
they're experimenting with a couple of
different ways of doing it one of one of
them is interpretive mode so they've
basically taken the runtime and compiled
it to web assembly and they're executing
they're executing c-sharp dll's directly
within the browser the other one is
ahead of time compilation so they're
actually compiling the dll directly to
web assembly and they're they're
experimenting with ease to side by side
blazer is a project that wraps around
Manos web assembly supports and it's a
fully featured single page application
framework so there's a lot of fun
c-sharp developers getting quite excited
about the potential of Blaser I don't
have anything practical show on c-sharp
and blazer because it's very very new
and I don't think anyone's done anything
practical with it quite yet so I guess
one of the final ones to talk
is is JavaScript so why why shouldn't
you compile JavaScript to web assembly
and there's a lot of people writing
react applications and all kinds of
other JavaScript based applications and
and you look at the features you get
with web assembly and you think yeah I'd
like some of that I'd like my JavaScript
to to pass more quickly to be optimized
immediately so there are a lot of people
trying to find creative ways to compile
JavaScript to web assembly and obviously
there are even more challenges there so
firstly you need a garbage collector
secondly it's not statically typed so
you've got typing as a bit of an issue
there are a couple of projects that I've
been keeping an eye on that are trying
to tackle this first is called Walt
which is a JavaScript like syntax for a
web assembly so what they've done is
they've taken that text-based format
which I've shown you and try to map it
as closely as possible to JavaScript so
it's it's a thin veneer on top of the
web assembly text format the other one
that I've actually had a bit of a go
with is assembly script so in order to
solve the typing issue that's pretty
straightforward with JavaScript these
days you've got things like flow and
typescript that introduce typing so with
typescript you can enforce typing of
your code and use a very similar
compilation path that you do for a c and
c++ and at the moment that project is is
in its early stages and they're
currently awaiting news of when garbage
collection will appear within web
assembly to make some fairly critical
design decisions about how they how they
tackle that I've actually got bit of a
demo hopefully I typed in the Wi-Fi
password so has anyone used d3 before
yeah cool yeah everyone loves d3 so this
is a d3 force layout but what I've done
is I've taken d3 force layout and taken
all of their algorithmic code and
rewritten it using typescript and
compiled it to web assembly so basically
the the standard sort of n-body
algorithm and the kind of Hookes law
spring concepts are all being computed
here within web assembly using
typescript and it was quite an
interesting experiment for me to see how
easy it is to take a JavaScript
application that wasn't written in
typescript add type information to it
and then compile it to web assembly and
work out how to
managed the interface between the two so
actually if you scroll down if you
scroll if I scroll down you can see it's
got it supports exactly the same API as
d3 itself but all the computations being
done in web assembly that that was good
fun I enjoyed that actually I'm going
one thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to get rid of that demo because it's got
memory leak yeah I know
the final one I want to briefly touch on
is is rust has anyone used rust here
before nope definitely the wrong room
for that oh you yeah so rust is gaining
popularity quite quickly if you ever
have a look at the sort of metrics Stack
Overflow does a survey every year and
they do quite a lot of data analysis and
rust seems to be a programming language
that makes people really really really
happy so it's a modern language it's a
very very popular language significantly
here it doesn't require a garbage
collector it's got quite an interesting
memory model that has the concept of
ownership so every every object that's
allocated on the heap is only ever owned
by one reference at one point in time
which makes it very very easy to reason
about memory and clean up memory it's
hard getting your head around it
initially but it's a good concept
so within rust what they did was they
used the EM scripting tool chain and are
actually investing time in creating some
better tool chains and I found this
quote actually from someone within the
Russ community that who says we're
poised to be the language of choice for
full web assembly and the reason for
that is it's a much-loved language and
because it doesn't need a garbage
collector it's actually in a great
position for for being compiled to web
assembly right now so I had a bit of a
play with it myself I created a a chip 8
emulator
so chip 8 is a a pretty old engine for
for playing arcade games I say engine it
was it was one the very first virtual
machines actually it was developed by
someone who at the time came up with a
concept for a virtual machine for
playing games that could then be
incorporated into a number of the the
current computers at the time it was a
great idea wasn't terribly successful
but it's great for people who want to
experiment with creative
emulators because it's actually quite a
simple machine to emulate so for me this
was great fun having a go at rust and
not I'd not used rust before so trying
to do rust right an emulator which I'd
not do before and then compile that to
web assembly that kept me up a lot of
nights but that was good fun but having
said that people are doing some really
practical and useful stuff with rust and
web assembly and again a lot of this is
coming out coming from Mozilla so in in
a very recent blog post they've talked
about some of the work they've done on
source maps so source maps is if you if
you're not aware what source Maps is
source Maps is a technology that allows
you to map that highly mangled version
of the code that runs in your browser to
the source code that you created in the
first place so sorts Maps are a way of
mapping from one representation of codes
to another and source map serve as you
can imagine quite computationally
intensive but the most popular source
Maps library that supports parsing and
understanding source maps is all written
in JavaScript and the team behind it
decided to take some of the most
performance critical logic rewrite it in
rust compile it to web assembly and then
evaluate the performance and you can see
here when the performance metrics they
were looking at was the time it takes
from setting a breakpoint to be able to
actually inspect your code so basically
to be able to to pass I don't have
parses the right word but understand the
source maps and map their breakpoint
back to your original code and as you
can see here the web assembly
performance I know the text is a bit
small there at the bottom but the web
assembly performance is these little
blue clusters so a couple of
observations the first one is clearly
web assembly is is quite a bit faster in
the order of two to three times faster
but another interesting aspect here is
the JavaScript performance you'll see
quite a spread in performance and that
is because again of the nature of the
way that JavaScript is executed it goes
through multiple tiers of optimization
where it might be optimized and then D
optimized and what that means is your
runtime performance isn't terribly
predictable whereas within web assembly
the runtime performance is highly
predictable in comparison so that was
that was a fan
blog post and a really interesting read
and the interesting thing is even though
this was done as an experiment if
they're happy with it if all the unit
tests run they can put that in
production now and everyone who uses
source Maps directly or indirectly is
then going to receive the performance
boost so finally I want to do their
crystal ball gazing so as I've shown you
that the current state of web assembly
is is is variable depending on language
and in terms of what people are doing
with it
again there's lots and lots of
experimentation but now I think we're
starting to see the signs of where it's
actually going to be used in the future
and how it's practically going to be
used so my prediction for 2018 is as you
can imagine lots more creativity mostly
coming out of languages like rust but
we're also seeing a lot of creativity
with c-sharp I have a feeling the Swift
community are going to be very very keen
on this because Swift has a lot of
common attributes with rust it's a
modern language it's quite a pleasant
language to use and also using arc
ultimate yeah automatic reference
counting it's got a memory model that's
quite compatible with web assembly also
within 2018 I don't know if you noticed
two days ago there was a new web pack
release version four and that included
web assembly support so web assembly as
a chain now allows you to import rust
directly within your code and web
assembly sorry web pack because it's
magic will do its magic and the right
thing will pop out the other ends
hopefully if you get your configuration
right so yeah if you get configuration
right it's great if it's not right then
it's hell but I also think that with in
2018 you'll start to see web assembly
sneaking into your daily workflow
without actually knowing it so as I
showed you right back at the beginning
when I create a react application it
adds 79 thousand lines of JavaScript to
my machine and most of that code is is
being used at build time very little bit
is actually being used at run time I
think that 79,000 is going to start
going down as people start to use web
assembly to hit performance critical
parts of your of your tolling another
thing I think you're going to start
seeing is native note modules using
webassembly I don't know about you but I
find it quite frustrating that the
workflow involved in using node modules
that have native code there's a lot of
friction there now there isn't a
terribly good reason to do that anymore
you can actually ship web assembly
instead so 2019 within web assembly
itself I'm pretty sure we'll start to
see garbage collection host binding
threading will start see web assembly
itself become a lot more powerful as a
result c-sharp and Java some of the
languages that require a garbage
collector will become first-class
citizens of the sort of web assembly an
ecosystem I think we're also going to
start seeing wasm UI frameworks so we're
going to start seeing UI frameworks that
are targeted that are entirely written
as web assembly in turn and and geared
towards perhaps c-sharp or java
developers and we're already starting to
see that I saw a project which was
called ASM Dom which was a virtual Dom
so modeling the react concept a virtual
Dom written in C++ compiling the web
assembly where's next year I think
that'll actually start to become a
practical option also I think we'll see
more of our our general plumbing move to
web assembly for example again using
reacts as an example it does some
computationally intensive tasks to do
the Dom dipping why not put that in web
assembly others other frameworks for
example there's a I think called the
glimmer VM which is a templating engine
which is in one of the UI frameworks
whose name I can't remember but I'm
pretty sure that will move to web
assembly as well interestingly though I
think we're going to start seeing rust
go Swift and other languages start to
gain some web market share you might
think that's a good thing you might
think that's a bad thing but I honestly
think it's going to start happening 2020
and beyond again I'm going to go back to
that quote the web has become the most
ubiquitous platform ever yet
historically by accident the only
language that is supported by the
browser is JavaScript I think in 2020
we're going to see that that being
challenged javascript will no longer be
the only language of the browser and the
web I also think people are going to
start making significant progress
towards compiling JavaScript
rectly to webassembly again for the very
reason that javascript is a perfectly
good language for writing web
applications there's absolutely nothing
wrong with it but at the same time as
JavaScript developers start seeing rust
developers and Swift developers benefit
from web assembly they are going to be
wanting to get some of that as well my
gut feeling is that the JavaScript
language itself will start to move
towards some of the typescript concepts
to allow web assembly compilation and if
you've been following the way that
typescript has evolved over time
typescript has deliberately stayed on a
relatively convergent path with the
JavaScript language itself I have a
feeling that some of these features
typing for example might become a
first-class feature of JavaScript in
order to allow us to compile to web
assembly finally I guess it regretfully
I do honestly think Java scripts
popularity will decrease a little bit
is anyone gonna throw anything at me
quite yet no maybe leave it a little bit
I'm a big JavaScript found myself honest
but no but I do honestly think and
JavaScript has got a monopoly at the
moment and in the web platform is
ubiquitous
I don't I think it's a safe bet that
JavaScript will start to have a bit of a
fight with some of these other languages
but at the same time I think the reach
of the web will increase even more so I
think through progressive web apps so
progressive web apps currently talked
about mostly within the context of
mobile but progressive web apps make a
lot of sense on the desktop as well so I
think a combination of progressive web
apps and the ability of web assembly to
allow you to do computationally
intensive complex operations will mean
things like Photoshop for example will
become a progressive web app I think
things like AutoCAD the AutoCAD team
already are looking at web assembly I
think the ubiquity of the web will
increase or the ability of JavaScript
will it will and web assembly will
increase and move more onto the desktop
so yeah that that pretty much brings me
to the end web assembly in the death of
JavaScript and I'm gonna say no it's
it's not gonna die but I think it's got
a real fight on its hands and if you
disagree you can start throwing things
at me right now
you
[Applause]